[Música]
l
ah
[Música]
hola
les propongo un desafío
yo les cuento un día de mi trabajo
y ustedes piensan cuando me pagarían por
él
[Música]
llegó aproximadamente nueve de la mañana
abro la sede
pongo el agua para el mate
chequeo los mensajes del teléfono
la agenda de actividades
los correos
participo de alguna reunión
interdisciplinaria
para poder abordar discutir alguna
situación problemática que haya llegado
como demanda
[Música]
viajo a compartir algún taller
destinado a niños adolescentes
teniendo en cuenta de no olvidar ningún
material y seguramente en el auto
vamos repasando con mis compañeros
con tengo alguna situación de plena
crisis de manera telefónica o personal
realizó alguna actividad de
mantenimiento de limpieza del lugar
voy al banco a la contadora recibo algún
colega de otro lugar
estoy atenta a las necesidades de algún
compañero
algunas aptitudes que consideran
necesarias para este trabajo tener
presente que para cada tarea hay
objetivos pautados
una buena comunicación una escucha
activa
alta disponibilidad en el trabajo en
equipo
estará atenta a las necesidades de los
otros porque realmente me interesa
aumentar pelan
tener presente
mis propias limitaciones
ahora bien
cuanto me pagarían ustedes por esto
[Música]
saben qué
mi trabajo rompe
rompe rompe con muchos prejuicios rompe
con muchos mandatos sociales rompe hasta
con la misma lógica del mercado
saben por qué porque mi trabajo es mucho
más que una mercancía
mi trabajo como el de muchas otras
personas
adolescentes jóvenes adultos adultos
mayores
es un trabajo voluntario
un trabajo voluntario
y muchas veces este tipo de trabajo es
difícil de entender
les cuento
hace 11 años
once años consecutivos días semanas años
y soy parte que trabajó en una
asociación civil de la ciudad de río
cuarto oasis
juntos tenemos por objetivo luchamos en
la prevención de la violencia
intrafamiliar
el abuso sexual infantil y el
fortalecimiento de los vínculos
familiares
qué objetivos no
quitaría
y realmente pensar
en este recorrido me atrapa en un cúmulo
es tan grande de emociones sentimientos
aprendizajes que hoy
se los quiero compartir
mi vida a nivel laboral
pero totalmente diferente muy distinta
a mis 17 años
comencé a trabajar
mi trabajo era diferente en el sentido
que sabemos que el trabajo voluntario no
es un trabajo remunerado económicamente
y muchas personas no lo entienden
te lo preguntan te lo cuestionan
entre ellos mis hijos
a los 17 años como les decía
conforme una familia conformamos una
familia si me casé cuando termine el
colegio secundario y comenzamos a
trabajar en un emprendimiento familiar
fabricábamos chinelas pantuflas
alpargatas
un trabajo en casa monotributistas
muchas horas
y noches también
luego de 15 años de este trabajo
decidimos concluir la actividad
y recuerdo que mi marido mi gran amor el
gran amor de mi vida me dice gris
ahora hace algo que realmente te haga
sentir bien y bueno aproveché comencé el
cambio
claro que para mis hijos que su infancia
había transcurrido entre chinelas
mamá comenzaba a salir a conocer a otras
personas muchas horas abocadas a este
nuevo trabajo sin ningún dinero a cambio
preguntas cuestionamientos enojos
explicaciones
su apoyo incondicional es tu siempre
y con el tiempo sin imponer nada
ellos fueron descubriendo una nueva
riqueza en su vida
de no solo pensar en sus alegrías y
necesidades
resultado de eso hoy tenemos el orgullo
de ser padres
de una bella bombero voluntaria y de dos
varones
con gran sensibilidad y responsabilidad
a lo social
les cuento que mi pasión fue creciendo
paulatinamente
recuerdo la primera vez que llegué a
oasis fui invitada por la fundadora
recuerdo que me dijo gris acércate este
sábado así nos conoces ves qué te parece
y desde ese extraordinario sábado
comencé a participar de cada reunión y
capacitación de voluntarios
fui conociendo a diferentes personas
compañeras y compañeros maravillosas
cuanto ejemplo seguir
y recibiendo todos los talleres
que ellos daban fortalecimiento de la
autoestima manejo del enojo comunicación
hacia una familia más saludable y
cuantos otros
fui dándome cuenta del funcionamiento
del lugar y de los diferentes equipos de
trabajo
pero por sobre todo me fue permitiendo
herramientas
que a nivel individual y después por
familiar sentía que transformaba en mi
forma de ser de pensar de percibir
y van transformándome
y cada día me iba enganchando más
en ese momento
creo que ya tenía la camiseta puesta
y va por más
quería ser tallerista quería compartir
todas estas herramientas y conocimientos
con otras personas con la comunidad
seguí formándome
operador comunitario mediación y
resolución de conflictos adolescencia y
salud
convenció participar de diferentes
congresos
con mis compañeros sobre abuso sexual
infantil
y fui tallerista primero de adultos de
niños niñas y desde hace ya cinco años
soy parte del equipo de talleristas de
adolescentes
cuántos recuerdos rondas sonrisas
miradas abra sus contenedores cuántas
veces nos decimos vamos por más vamos
que se puede
este recorrido también me dio la
oportunidad de ser parte de una comisión
directiva como secretaria vicepresidenta
presidenta cuánta responsabilidad cuánto
trabajo en equipo
cuantos momentos de buscar estrategias
para seguir trabajando siempre
con recursos económicos muy escasos pero
con muchas ganas y mucha voluntad
este trabajo voluntario me llevó romper
con prejuicios cuántas veces hemos
escuchado el trabajo voluntario es
asistencialismo el trabajo voluntario es
ayudar a los demás es filantropía
y la verdad que mi experiencia me dice
lo contrario
el trabajo voluntario para mí es algo
más diferente es algo mucho más profundo
es tener un corazón abierto una mirada
sensible lo social
es poder considerar
a las personas
que si portan necesidades problemas
dificultades pero por sobre todo
por tan habilidades y capacidades y
derechos
que los tenemos que tener en cuenta a la
hora de poder acompañarlos a resolver un
problema
no es una simple acción de dar
es mucho más que eso
no es que me levanto mágicamente y digo
hoy hoy voy a ser voluntario porque le
ayudo un vecino empujar su auto
no
es un camino es un recorrido es una
decisión es poder planificar buscar
acciones
organizadas
siempre partiendo de un trabajo en
equipo
con objetivos con compromiso con
creatividad
y consideró la necesidad de que se
necesitan organizaciones asociaciones
agrupaciones sociales
en donde el voluntario puedas
identificarse
puede hacer parte y tomar la decisión de
comenzar
a trabajar
ser voluntario realmente me inquieta
me lleva a seguir rompiendo a seguir
buscando y me animé me animaron
con 41 años decidí
comenzar
una carrera universitaria
cuántos miedos
pero lo hice
y licenciatura en trabajo social
la verdad que me llena de felicidad me
llena de orgullo esta decisión
me llena de conocimientos me permite
poder ver analizar tensionar
problematizar la realidad de diferentes
maneras
y este caminar y transitar la
universidad
me ha dado el regalo de conocer a
personas maravillosas a nuevos vínculos
mis compañeros mis compañeras
cuántos momentos intensos compartidos
mates parciales finales
sentir un momento que la experiencia
sola no bastaba que necesitaba algo más
que necesitaba de conocimientos teóricos
de perspectivas
que reforzarán no solo mi vocación
sino mi mirada a la realidad
mi lucha el cambio social
ser voluntario ser voluntaria
a veces sentir realmente que lo
compartes todo pero maravillosamente y
sin esperarlo recibí mucho más
es un ida y vuelta una retroalimentación
y salirte de tu mundo personal para
abrir tu mundo mucho más rico más
empático compartiendo parte de tu tiempo
de tus saberes
de tus habilidades
deja de sentirte el pulpo del mundo
a brito a verdaderos caminos de
transformación
comparte una parte de tu tiempo un
proyecto en común un nuevo sueño
después de un camino recorrido
y seguramente
tanto a recorrer
tengo la total convicción de que muchas
cosas los recrean día a día el compartir
el encuentro las luchas
el otro la justicia social
anímate a ser voluntario yo estoy
totalmente agradecida de serlo te dejo
volando esta idea gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
ah
[Música]